when a treat is within reach healthy  rats have no problem threading a paw  through a slot to snatch the suit  grabbing the grub becomes much more  difficult when the animals suffered  damage to the region of the brain that  controls movement the damage in this  case is similar to what a person might  experience after a traumatic brain  injury to correct the rats reaching  problem scientists designed a patch that  route signals from one region of the  brain to another the patch which fits  inside the skull helped the injured  animals regain the ability to reach out  and grab food after two weeks the  animals performance was as good as it  had been before the brain injury the  team reports the result December ninth  and the Proceedings of the National  Academy of Sciences with work the patch  could be used to repair human brain  damage from stroke blast injuries and  diseases such as Parkinson's